yeah
yeah like you guys just did as well I
mean you guys yeah what an amazing
segment yeah
I'm speaking of Charities we did so we
did the cycle uh Christmas Friday 700
and I'm gonna say 750 it was 750
something because if you keep going up
every time I said there is 800 now what
happened to us is that we the way we
calculated the overall distance we just
put Hokkaido oh sorry how could that day
what can I cycle they said this many
kilometers obviously we didn't we didn't
take the perfect route you didn't yeah
because you can't yeah because you would
want to stop and stay at hotels
it was cool though we we raised 300 000
316
000 yeah the IDF Israeli defensive
it's so unfortunate whenever you type in
whenever you type in the idea
it got really awkward the entire stream
people like guys I'm all for charity
fundraising why is it the Israeli
Defense Force it's the it's immune
deficiency Foundation is there it's
there on the stream it says immune
deficiency Foundation it got very heated
very political I can't believe they're
supporting this yeah
um no it was good what I didn't like was
being referred to as Jeffrey yeah
he's asking for massages
we had our friend American P Premiere 2
coming out yeah the second half which we
needed because we were dead by the
second half and he like pepped it up and
I was like if you want to come on if you
want to come on the cycle Pete you got
to pay the price back rub time and
people like you're just Jeff rebsters
um yeah but you know to be fair you get
you want to come on the trip you've got
to pay the price
those massages got me through the second
half of the [ __ ] cycle all right you
had a personal massage that was uh so I
spoke about it a bit in one of the other
episodes but I only spoke about kind of
like the technical aspect in the Stream
aspect yeah so I didn't really tell any
of the stories or any of the there was a
story stories I heard you guys went to a
racist hotel or something like that I'd
let Chris tell that yeah oh there's not
much to it we went in a hotel and they
were just incredibly not overly
welcoming yeah like how so like was it
like in a it was like an aggressive
manner or it was like a kind of very
cold manner all right and then
aggressive and then aggressive because
you know like Japan is very good at
being you know doing the passive
aggressive stuff yeah I mean we there
was a hotel in the middle of nowhere on
the second day literally nothing nowhere
to stay yeah we stopped in this town
called Naka gawa by the Riverside or
something yeah right there's one place
that was open for the 50 kilometer
radius of that area and we tried to book
it and they're like no room at the end
we're full oh [ __ ] we also read a book
like a month in advance we did right
there's no room rooms and then we we
rang them up and uh we rang up in
English first and that that didn't go
down well so we rang that we got one of
our friends to bring them up in like
perfect Japanese one room but we needed
two rooms one for me and Connor one for
our driver and cameraman pool and Ian
yeah and um but there wasn't so they had
to drive all the way back a hundred
kilometers to walk on it
again yeah there were four guys
but we sort of went to check in and the
woman was just really like
it wouldn't like look at me in the face
all the stuff just went like completely
silent the air left it was like oh [ __ ]
this is awkward and I was like oh I
don't suppose you've got one more room
available our friends are in the car
park and they were like right I was like
well they've gonna have to drive all
back to work now it's all right for lava
and they're like
it was just like this is so awkward and
like so we got our room keys we'll be
like oh so they sort of like walked off
and looked like they weren't doing
anything so we're like okay let's go to
our room 10 15 seconds of them just like
not saying anything yeah yeah and they
gave us the key so we started walking
off to our room and then the door opened
and the woman came running out she was
like you've got to pay pay for your room
now we were like what oh my God Jesus
like he did you look like he did hold on
shouting it was right really awkward
really you know just because I it was
just a bit awkward uncomfortable we were
just like oh all right fine you could
have just said so yeah yeah and four
years yeah that was the only real bad
bit and then we did try and get into a
restaurant in waikanae which you guys
yeah right
destitute remote city was it McDonald's
honestly I remember when we went to
McDonald's that place was banging out of
like yeah it was like kicking off like
half the town was there I swear to God
it's always full I swear the twice I've
been there now it's been always full and
there's like always people taking photos
of the Ronald McDonald out the front of
the bed yeah it's the most northern
Ronald McDonald in Japan yeah Donald
McDonald yeah yeah he's called Donald
McDonald in Japan because they realized
Ronaldo is too difficult for tongue
twister yeah I love those I'll just call
it Donald McDonald then yeah
it's hard to sell with Hotel staff if or
any staff in Japan it's like are they
are they always this rude to everyone or
is it just because we're here well I
don't think they'd ever seen a foreign
person there before oh it's so remote
because you had to book it in Japanese
for this website but we also went to a
restaurant in wacanae and it was a
Yakitori chicken skewed restaurant I was
like this is gonna be great I'm gonna
eat the whole restaurant dry walked in
and the guy was like no get out and
we're like oh really yeah like don't
[ __ ] come here I didn't even ask him
there was like empty tables and it
looked like it was like is it open yeah
it's open for another
so those first two days it was just like
oh let's enjoy racism
after that it got better Thomas everyone
was so nice that's really weird there
was a lot of everyone was kind after
that it's just that part of Japan and
maybe they're not racist they're just
very shy and uncomfortable well I think
it's also because like if I mean for one
obviously not a lot of foreigners go up
there like this I feel there's like a
hard line in Hokkaido where you go
anywhere north of there and it's just
immediately like foreigners don't come
here yeah yeah
and South everyone was very nice yeah
because they're probably more used to
foreign
yes we cycled off just as this girl
arrived and she had to deal with our
team in the car who were there not
really bad so she was like I just missed
them I can't go to the next stop either
oh oh we ran into a guy I think he's
from the Czech Republic there and he was
walking from wakanae to kagoshima doing
your road trip in reverse and walking it
over a four-month period yeah
and I saw what I thought was our
cameraman pull up ahead and I was like
yeah he sort of waved me over and I was
like that's not Paul that's not Paul at
all and he's just a really nice guy and
he's like I've got plums for you yeah
excellent and he just whipped out some
plums yeah ate the plums and but yeah
he's walking for four months Jesus holy
[ __ ] and he just started his journey
yeah he was two weeks in I think yeah
yeah you started in the very very top of
uh what can I I don't know all the way
to kagoshima Jesus Jesus far out yeah
it's like Homer's Odyssey
the guy tweeted at me on Twitter yeah a
few days before saying oh I might bump
into you and how could I say I'm walking
from the top to bottom I'm like this
guy's lying
I'm like that's that's absurd you're one
no one is doing that's literally like
Forrest Gump yeah I think that's what
forested I don't know it just seemed
weird I and it didn't make sense to me
so I was like oh whatever but then yeah
it's like and it's like you're not even
doing it for Content
what's wrong with you you're just doing
it for fun and I saw that a guy had
stopped him like ahead of me yeah it
must be that dude because like we're in
how could that who already said yeah it
didn't look like any of our cameraman or
staff yeah so I was like that's weird so
as slow as it gets closer I see the
giant backpack I'm like oh my God it's
him yeah it's real Jesus Christ what a
legend though I saw those words I would
not want to walk on yeah just there's
trucks it's just all trucks I mean
another girl called Melissa yeah I came
out of like a bickery donkey restaurant
and everyone was like talking to her and
getting free crisps and stuff yeah she
brought us like a bunch of drinks
I felt no it's really really great
really nice positive people yeah yeah
that's good aside from just the one few
people at the beginning of the journey
pretty much pretty much yeah but it was
it was it was tough though and like we I
only nearly killed Connor once yeah we
only had one may drive in one time I
heard you guys had a domestic but
full-on domestic about when to wake up
right it's a shame the cameras weren't
rolling because that would be a great
like coming up section
you have to bleep the c word like four
times in our defense like so this was
the middle of the trip in sapro like the
just past the halfway point yeah and
we'd done what was optimistically build
as the easy day right but it was like
the most difficult day
um it was only like 60 kilometers to
Sapporo it was like we'll get there
before lunchtime would be brilliant but
then we hit 30 kilometer headwinds and
Google was like take a detour with extra
20 kilometers and we didn't really look
while we were going to [ __ ] Google
[ __ ] us up Google [ __ ] us and we got
this apparel and I was just just wrecked
I was like I don't know how I'm gonna be
able to carry on this yeah and it was
like right we've got three more days and
then hard days and I was like [ __ ]
sake 100 it was like 100 kilometers 100
kilometers 164 kilometers yeah it was it
was it was a lot and then I think we had
a 90 to wake up and yeah yeah it was it
was yeah it got heated but then we were
like very quickly we were like all right
cool it Conor was like we worked out
that at the current rate we'd have to
wake up like four o'clock in the morning
yeah I wouldn't be up at 4am for my own
funeral oh yeah foreign
yeah and some days we were really fast
it just depended on the win the mood the
wind and the how much good road we're on
yeah the road made so like even if it
just had like was a little bump it would
just slow you down so much when you had
like a good paved Road you could just
get that's so much more distance done so
fast yeah I don't know it's weird but I
noticed that I I started off really
strong started getting worse and worse
and Chris definitely got better I think
it was too late only the first four days
I could barely stand up I was like the
[ __ ] Hobbit that the first hobbling
along like I'm never walking again but
then after I raised my seat I was like
oh right this is really oh this is this
is meant to be done actually normally
yeah normally when you pedal right your
feet go like this right just but Chris's
we're going like like this
everyone in my chat was something what
the [ __ ] and I was running like what are
you doing
my legs are fine on the second half but
I got really bad back pain from like
leaning down leaning forward yeah yeah
that got really bad I had to take some
painkillers to get through but yeah the
the sad thing is there not even the
massage could cover for you
Jeffrey Broad Street massages